okay so we are covering probably the
most important Miles Morales story in
the history of Marvel Comics but also
one of the more controversial stories
that Marvel had done in the history of
Marvel in recent years which is Ultimate
end now a little bit of backstory
because this does tie into Secret Wars
and it's a part of Secret Wars so for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with how Secret Wars unfolded in 2015
which seems to be the version that we're
going to be getting when it comes to the
secret Wars film in the MCU that this
all started with a variety of things
right you'll find a link to the entire
playlist in the comments section but
what this did is it basically gave us
the collapse of the Multiverse now I'm
not going to go into detail in terms of
how all that happened check out the
video for that but what is important
here is that with the collapse of the
Multiverse Dr Doom had basically seized
the power of the beyonders for himself
which effectively made him God and in
doing so what he ended up basically
doing was pulling together different
pieces of alternate realities across the
Multiverse and combining them into a
kind of Patchwork called battle world
and so you literally have all these
different alternate realities just kind
of sitting side by side so you have like
the Marvel Zombies universe and then
like right next to it is the Age of
Ultron Universe where Ultron conquered
everything right it's just this small
isolated pocket and you can go from one
place to the next although you're not
supposed to right like they're not
supposed to cross from what's called a
domain so you're not supposed to leave
your domain and go to a different one
and so what matters here and what's
important here is that this entire story
takes place within the confines of
battle World itself but there are going
to be things that people who are
familiar with Secret Wars are going to
be asking about I will clarify all that
stuff by the time we get to the end of
the video but what this does is it
initially opens up with the Ultimate
Universe and the main Marvel Universe
meeting and talking now this is kind of
cool because what had happened here at
the very beginning of Secret Wars in
issue number zero is you had the
Ultimate Universe and the main Marvel
universe as the last two universes in
existence everything else had basically
been wiped out they were on a collision
course it was the final incursion they
were all fighting each other and then
everything blinked right because of
Doctor Doom and all that stuff
everything basically collided it blinked
and then battle world came into
existence so one one thing that I do
want to establish here is that like most
people across the entirety of the battle
World Secret Wars event most people
don't actually know the truth of what Dr
Doom did all they know is the life that
Dr Doom gave them and the fact that
Docker Doom rules from on high and
that's it that's really all they know
and so what's kind of crazy here is
Bendis sort of takes his own turn and
again what makes sense of all of this he
establishes that there was basically a
kind of dimensional Rift that had been
established in the ultimate universe
that it effectively combined the
Ultimate Universe and the main Marvel
universe together into one single domain
that they used to be separate now this
is where things get a little murky
because what ends up happening here is
we're visited or at least we see the
arrival of Peter Parker at this giant
Gathering now there's also familiar
faces here right like Scott Summers Emma
Frost so on and so forth but Peter
Parker showing up here and meeting with
everybody initially he's just kind of
obsessed about the fact that everybody
seems to know his identity the bigger
concern here that they have is that
because the main Marvel Universe and
because the Ultimate Universe were at
one point two different domains but but
their dimensional tampering led to the
domains combining that Dr Doom may very
well become aware of what it is that
they've done and that if he does there's
only one of two possibilities either he
allows it to sort of continue on and
just sort of do its thing which presents
a dangerous precedent because it means
that other people in other domains can
start experimenting with dimensional
Rifts and potentially discover the truth
of what Dr Doom did or Dr Doom will
intervene in some capacity and so this
kind of splits the group in half those
who say that they need to report their
findings to doom and others who say they
don't and in fact this really seems to
be a stark contrast no pun intended
between both versions of Tony Stark and
so this is where we get this kind of
cool explanation because we actually
learn the basis behind this portal now
if you've been reading the Ultimate
Universe or at least you were at this
point in time you know all of this right
so just bear with me for people who
don't so what happened here at a distant
point in the past is that when Peter
Parker in the Ultimate Universe died
Miles Morales became the new Spider-Man
and initially fans weren't overly
receptive to it and so in order to just
kind of put the kibosh on that and to
establish that Miles wasn't going
anywhere Brian Michael Bendis who was
riding miles at the time wrote a story
called Spider-Man and this involved the
opening of a portal which I want to say
was by the vulture but I'm not going to
swear to that that basically saw Peter
Parker from The main Marvel Universe
crossing over into the Ultimate Universe
and that's how he and Miles met for the
very first time they had a kind of
adventure together and then when miles
told Peter that the Peter Parker and his
reality had died the main Marvel
Universe Spider-Man gave miles his
Blessing and said you now have my
blessing to become a Spider-Man in this
universe carry on the legacy of your
reality's version of Peter Parker go go
forth and be a superhero and it was
basically been just telling all the
people who were not fans of miles to
shut up and he wasn't going anywhere and
it worked but what this story
establishes is that the portal never
actually was shut down and so what ended
up happening is the portal effectively
exploded outward and then merged the
Ultimate Universe and the main Marvel
Universe into one single reality and
they've been here ever since right now
this is where things are kind of cool
and I think this is a good chance to
explain this the way that secret Wars on
initially unfolded is that when it came
to the collapse of the Multiverse there
was no main Marvel Universe anymore and
there was no Ultimate Universe anymore
right like there was nothing it was
simply just those superheroes who
survived and those superheroes who were
plucked from what few realities remained
by Doctor Doom and thrown onto battle
world what Brian Michael Bendis is
establishing here is that within battle
World itself is a main Marvel Universe
and an Ultimate Universe it was
basically vendus trying to do his own
thing and sort of wrap up the entirety
of the Marvel Multiverse in his own way
but the thing about this is that once
the groups separate and they go their
own ways this leads to the arrival of
the Thor Court they are by extension the
law of Doom right so whenever they come
down and they say this is going to
happen everybody in battle World treats
it as Doom's work because the
alternative is to be killed by the Thor
court and in fact that's exactly what
happens that when they're told by the
Thor core itself do not mess with this
dimensional gate leave it alone right
have no involvement here whatsoever so
says the the word of Doom Hawkeye
challenges it right and Hawkeye says no
that's not gonna happen right we're
going to do whatever it is that we need
to do and the Thor core shows him on the
spot literally just eradicates him on
the spot now that's one thing to
understand is under any normal
circumstance Thor could be rivaled by
any number of of heroes or villains who
are out there given varying degrees of
power the Thor core's power was elevated
by Dr Doom to allow them to overcome
virtually any foe out there the
exception to this was when they met
Thanos when Thanos survived the collapse
of the Multiverse and he showed up with
like the the col obsidian right like the
black order and like the different
villains and just demolish the Thor core
which was amazing
apocalypse did it too this is why I tell
you guys you need to check out the
playlist in the comments section after
this video is done because Avengers New
Avengers Secret Wars The Greatest Story
Ever Told in the history of Marvel
Comics it's phenomenal but of course
with Hawkeye being killed and the groups
coming to the realization that at least
for the moment if they are gonna mess
with this portal they have to keep it
Hush Hush they can't just go out there
and just sort of do it brazenly you end
up having main Marvel Universe Iron Man
and Ultimate Iron Man meeting with each
other and kind of having a bit of a sit
down right in a bit of a conversation
and in fact it's one of these things
where they sort of come to terms on how
in the world could we possibly fix this
get things back to the way that they're
supposed to be so we have our domain you
have your domain and that's effectively
it the other part of this is we get one
of the coolest moments when it comes to
like ultimate Hulk fighting main Marvel
Universe Hulk and that's one of the cool
things that did come out of ultimate
into a degree was that it was sort of a
love letter for like all the different
little battles and things that we'd
wanted to see over the years but never
really saw like who would win in a fight
ultimate Hulk main Marvel Hulk which one
of the two is the strongest that kind of
a thing the way this kind of played out
though is that you ended up having main
Marvel Universe Bruce Banner who was
just kind of continuing his experiments
and Research into like dimensional riffs
and so on and so forth kind of uh the
other half of the equation from what
both Tony Starks were doing but the
ultimate Banner showed up to meet him
and as the two of them were talking you
actually had this kind of disagreement
between the two which was surface level
at best and it was just reason for
Benders to have these guys start
fighting each other which was awesome
like it was really cool for what it was
but the entire basis behind their
disagreement is sort of an argument of
futility right that Ultimate Universe
Bruce Banner is very very just cynical
right and he is in a lot of ways a
nihilist just by virtue of him seeing
the Incredible Hulk Persona is more of a
curse than anything else he just kind of
believes life is meaningless right
there's no point in continuing on and
really even no point in anything at all
the difference here though is that
Banner from the main Marvel universe is
a lot more hopeful now a lot of this is
because of what was going on with the
character of The Incredible Hulk at this
point in time specifically Jason Aaron's
run which gave us a kind of reworked
version of Professor Hulk and so it was
kind of uh more powerful but also
equally intelligent version of the
professor Hulk that we'd seen in years
past which was basically a Hulk with the
mind of Bruce Banner right this that
kind of a thing but with the two of
these guys having totally different
viewpoints that ultimately the cynicism
of Bruce Banner from the Ultimate
Universe just gets the better of
literally main model a universe banner
and it refers to Ultimate Banner as a
coward and that leads to like tempers
flaring the two of them fighting and
then literally like main Marvel Universe
Hulk just like sends ultimate Hulk
flying through the raft prison right
Riker's prison where like all the super
powered beings in that area are being
held it literally just causes a riot and
one of the people who just starts
inciting their wrath on everybody around
there is the Punisher which is amazing
because this Earth 616 Punisher right
the main Marvel Universe Punisher this
guy survives this guy made it out which
is awesome honestly I'm not 100 sure how
I agree with that because during like
the secret Wars or maybe it was The
Punisher last days I want to say it was
Secret Wars though Secret Wars issue
number zero when the world was ending
The Punisher like shows up in a bar
where you have all these villains and
he's just like he's like Such a Pity
it's the end of the world and I have all
these bullets what am I gonna do with
them and he kills every villain in the
bar he just sprays them all down
mercilessly but the thing about this is
that he actually ends up meeting his
Ultimate Universe counterpart which is
kind of a funny thing because there's a
bit of a fight between the two of them
and then main Marvel Universe Punisher
just seemingly comes out on top which is
cool right it's just one of these these
cool little moments here but again like
what you have here in a lot of ways is
that with tempers flaring with a lot of
anger and resentment and rage and just
frustration with this sort of
overcrowded environment right these two
realities cram together it was only a
matter of time before things went to pot
exceedingly fast and so what this does
pretty quickly actually is it leads to
just like an all-out almost kind of like
a mini Civil War among like the heroes
and villains within this reality itself
now those individuals who are focusing
more on the dimensional Rift and so on
and so forth they're kind of hands off
right they're kind of doing their own
thing but this massive Calamity and this
massive battle does not go unnoticed and
in fact there's a point where
effectively Valeria ends up approaching
Doctor Doom now the thing about this and
the reason why it's so important is
because within the realm of Secret Wars
itself and as far as Dr Doom goes one of
the things that he had done is he had
found an alternate reality version of
Susan storm Franklin Richards and
Valeria Richards and then adopted them
as his own in effect he stole the life
of Reed Richards Mr Fantastic that was
kind of his thing and that actually
becomes a major focal point towards the
end of Secret Wars and the reason why it
ends the way it does but Valeria being
the head of the Science Foundation right
the Future Foundation effectively
approaches him and says given our
intelligence some kind of a dimensional
Rift was activated within the Ultimate
Universe domain and that led to the
Ultimate Universe domain and the main
Marvel Universe domain combining into
one and they're continuing to experiment
with this despite being expressly told
by your Thor core to stop doing it now
we don't know exactly what's going to
happen we don't know what's on the other
side of this dimensional Rift there may
be nothing there could potentially be
everything that could reach a realm
beyond anything that we've ever
discovered the realm of gods right the
one above all who really even knows
right no one knows for sure and she says
but even within the group itself they're
split one half of the group believes
they should report their findings to you
the other half believes they should
continue operating in secret all the
while blissfully unaware that we know
everything that they're doing and so she
asked him what was even the point right
Valeria asked him like what was even the
point of allowing this to happen in the
first place of putting two realities so
close together knowing that at some
future point in time they were going to
end up combining by whatever Manner and
whatever means and then just kind of
sitting back and allowing complete and
total pandemonium to unfold now there's
a reason for this and we'll talk about
why this reason exists in the first
place because what it does is it ties
into the original version of battle
world that Dr Duma created before he had
wiped everything out and started over
again and so if Valeria asked like where
Doctor Doom doesn't answer her and
Valeria asks do you want us to step in
do you want us to do anything like you
know doctor Doom's response is no right
like do not do anything let things
unfold as they will and she asked the
question but what happens if something
takes place that we can't foresee
something that happens that changes
everything enter Miles Morales now this
is one of the most important parts of
the story and the reason for this is
again when the Multiverse ended in
Secret Wars issue number zero that what
you had were these two kind of like life
wrath really one for what were
effectively the villains if you want to
call them that right the Ultimate
Universe version of Mr Fantastic along
with Thanos his coal obsidian and then
in turn you had the other raft for what
were basically the good guys Peter
Parker Spider-Man Miles Morales the
goodread richers from the main Marvel
Universe and a handful of others that
what had taken place here is that when
the Multiverse collapsed those wraths
actually just kind of existed out there
in The Ether and then ultimately arrived
on Battle world now there was some time
displacement hijinks and things like
that that we're not going to get into
the point being Miles Morales showing up
here he knows exactly what's going on he
understands exactly what's happening
here he knows everything that's taking
place and he's about to spill the beans
but not necessarily in the most direct
way in fact he fires his webbing over
everybody and just says stop now
initially he goes to explain everything
but Emma Frost basically steps up and
says look as a psychic I can tell you
right now if you tell them everything
you know none of them are going to
believe you they're all going to think
you're crazy the only way for them to
know is to be shown and so Emma Frost
uses her telepathic ability to basically
combine the minds or at least to project
the mind of miles into the mind of
everybody else here and that's when they
come into the realization of what's
going on now this is the explanation I'm
sure a lot of you guys have been waiting
for hopefully you guys find it
interesting so when everything was going
on with the multiversal collapse right
the beyonders and the molecule men and
all that kind of stuff that there was
basically a last-ditch effort by Dr Doom
and the molecule man Owen Reese and
Doctor Strange to defeat the beyonders
they did this by taking all the molecule
men that will remain from across the
Multiverse who were like these Universe
sized bombs literally when a molecule
man dies it blows up the whole universe
that what happened is all these molecule
men were basically just thrown at the
beyonders and blew all the beyonders up
and then eradicated basically all of the
Multiverse except for the main Marvel
Universe and the ultimate universe
itself and so that's what set these two
worlds on a collision course assuming we
ignore everything this bindis has been
doing with regards to the portal in the
dimensional Rift and all that kind of
stuff and so what happen here is that
once Dr Doom had seen the beyonders
defeated he took the entirety of their
power then he created the first version
of battle world now it's not directly
mentioned here in the story but the
original version of battle world as it
was shown and disgust in secret Wars
from 2015 was that it was a place of
suffering right it was just Only the
Strong deserve to survive those
individuals who were too weak were
perished it was like Warfare almost 100
of the time there was no light because
there was no sun and then Dr Doom
started to realize that this world was
destined to fail it was destined to fall
apart and So what had happened is that
he had completely reworked the entirety
of battle world just re-established
everything when Johnny Storm of the
Fantastic Four tried to fight him he
basically took away Johnny Storm's own
ability to control himself sent him out
into what you could call space kind of
the area orbiting battle world and
turned him into the Sun and so he lights
battle world now and battle world is had
basically become what it is now but all
this information is spilled directly to
everyone body here by Miles Morales that
God King Doom is not some being who has
always existed and he's always been God
and he's all-powerful and you always
have to listen to him at one point he
was just a dude and then a team just an
insane level of power and used it to
recreate the entirety of the Multiverse
and sees absolute control over
everything and so once they all start to
realize what's going on then they all
realize okay now their main enemy is
Doctor Doom and so what ends up
happening is they join basically
everybody else in the final fight
against Doom over a doom stat now that's
actually covered in the main secret War
Story itself but the funny thing about
this is that with everything going on
what ends up happening is that all these
different characters kind of start
blinking out of existence where they
kind of start disappearing the reason
behind this is because what's going on
behind the scenes is the conclusion of
the story where Reed Richards and Doctor
Doom are fighting and the molecule man
takes the power from Doom gives it to
read and Reed recreates everything so in
effect it's a reset right to a degree I
mean Marvel should have rebooted but
they didn't because they were recovered
so basically everybody kind of vanishes
and things sort of go back to normal the
way that they were supposed to but the
reason why this is so important for
Miles Morales right it's one of the most
important things for his character when
he gets back to the Ultimate Universe
when he's sleeping he wakes up to his
mom now this is why this is so important
because his mom's dead right now there's
a whole reason why this happens and it's
the reason that you would least expect
right but Miles Morales gets his mom
back this sets everything going forward
into the future of the Ultimate Universe
miles in the main Marvel universe is
part of all new all different Marvel so
for the guys who are always curious how
it is that Miles mom came back to life
this was it right this is how she came
back it was a gift from the molecule man
Owen Reese for one of the coolest things
that Miles Morales ever could have done
it was phenomenal but again we're gonna
bring this video to an end make sure you
guys check out the link in the comments
section for like the entirety of the
Avengers New Avengers secret War story
because it's phenomenal thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later
peace